بين اكوام الركام وجد عمال الانقاذ اخيرا
طريقا للوصول الى احدى الجثث التي كانت
مدفونه تحت الانقاذ فهذا الطفل الثاني
الذي نشاهده وكان ايضا
رضيعا بعض السكان ممن يعيشون بالجوار
قالوا ان عشره افراد ممن كانوا يسكنون هذا
المنزل قد قضوا في القصف بينما تقول
اسرائيل انها كانت تستهدف احد نشطاء حماس
ويدعى يحيى بياعه وهو مسؤول عن مجموعه
لاطلاق الصواريخ الامر الذي نفاه الناس
الذين تحدثنا
معهم وهذا هو منزل عائله
الدلو اخبرنا الناس هنا بان الذين قتلوا
كانوا من النساء والاطفال وانهم لم
يتمكنوا من العثور على الناجي وقبل لحظات
وفي تلك الزاويه تمكنوا من سحب جثه طفل
ولا تزال هناك جهود حثيثه تبذل للبحث بين
الارقام ويسيطر الغضب والاحباط على
الكثيرين
هنا
وهنا كانت تعيش قريبته التي عثر على جثتها
اخيرا ولا يوجد في غزه صفارات انذار او
ملاجئ فهذه الضربه كانت بدون سابق انذار
وبالتالي لم تكن جهود الانقاذ
مجديه وليس ببعيد من هنا وبالتحديد قبل
يوم واحد فالرضيع عامر الذي يبلغ من العمر
تسعه اشهر واخته ابنه الاربع سنوات تم
انقاذهما بعد غارات صاروخيه استهدفت
المنزل حيث يقتنون ام هيك راسي بقى مبين
بقوا الشباب يدخلوا يدخلوا راسهم ويشوفوا
راسي يمسكوا ايدي ما يقدرو يسحبو صور كبير
تقريبا قد هذا فوق رجلي معلقه رجلي مش
قادره احركها يسحبوا فيا ما ما قدرتش يعني
تقريبا ثث ساعه نص ساعه الا خمس دقائق
وانا تحت الانقاض وهذا ما يبدو عليه منزل
العائله الان اموت وانا متخيلاه يعني كل
صاروخ دبوه يعني بنزل بحسه على الدار اللي
انا فيها حتى الان مش مصدقه انهم يعني هم
اودي حتى بحكي مع حالي انهم هدول مش اودي
يعني مش متخيله يعني مش متخيله كيف طلعوا
مش حاسه حالي انا مش انا يعني مش مصدقه
يعني انا طلعت وانا عايشه وبحكي معكم
وبتكلم وبتنفس وفي روحه واولادي كمان يعني
اذا طلعت بطلع واحد هذه السيده اخبرتنا
بانها تريد الانتقام ولكنها ترغب بالسلام
اكثر لان لا شيء جيد ياتي من الحرب وانه
ولا
واحد y